[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon good afternoon my name is
Ellen Harris I'm head of music and
theatre arts here at MIT and I'm
delighted to be able to introduce the
second colloquium celebrating the 50th
anniversary of the School of Humanities
Arts and Social Sciences the colloquia
in celebration of the anniversary are
all composed under the title asking the
right questions
which became very important in the
question period following the first
colloquium where we learned that one
needed to ask the right questions I
believe to a certain extent that's what
art is is asking the right questions and
we will be doing more of that this
afternoon the question in the title of
our colloquium which is how do artists
tell their stories in itself I think
asks for further questions whose story
the artists if not whose story what kind
of story 50 years ago at MIT
Bernice Abbott created photographs that
told stories about wave force magnetism
and the nature of light and the
high-speed photography of MIT professor
Harold Edgerton depicted stories about
motion and impact that had never been
told before the counterpoint of art and
technology at MIT tells us that art and
design are inextricably linked that a
fragment or a flash of insight contains
a story as much as a lengthy narration
and that art tells stories about itself
about the world and about our place
in it the artists on today's panel deal
with questions fragments stories and
narrations of many kinds I'm reminded of
mi t--'s famed mechanical engineering
contest where students are given a box
of materials and told to build a
specific device artists toolboxes in
addition to such grammatical tools as
rhythm phrase tempo metre which are
things all of our panel is steel with in
different ways their toolboxes in
addition are full of questions to ask
and questions to answer in the afternoon
this afternoon we will explore some of
those by way of introduction to the
panelists I would like to share with you
some of their words about their work
that I found relevant to our discussion
this afternoon I refer you to the
program for their biographies and for
the honours that they have each received
which are the length of my arm and I
will not repeat them but you can find
them in your program the reason I do
this is because this panel is somewhat
odd in the sense that all of the other
panels the panelists get to talk their
work what they are presenting is their
work they haven't been asked to tell us
how they do their work or what their
work means but rather they present their
work one of the things we're going to do
this afternoon in order to make that
clear is that each of our panelists will
present something of his or her own work
in the course of their presentation so
that they will not simply be asked as if
we had a comic here and asked the comic
not to tell any jokes but only to
explain what a joke is and we will not
do that to our artists this afternoon
our first speaker will be John Harvison
an institute professor at MIT who in
1995 gave the James R Killian junior
faculty achievement lecture the title of
his lecture was the beauty of senseless
objects in a market economy he spoke
directly to this spirit of inquiry and
of risk-taking that the creative process
demands he talked about the courage to
birth and honor an idea he spoke of the
generation of a composition and he did
so interestingly in a series of
questions he said what starts the piece
going what makes you begin where do you
recognize the beginning and what happens
from that point to the point that we've
just experienced the question then
becomes what are we looking for and what
stops us what is the thing that happens
in our minds that makes us think that we
want to pursue some sort of idea with
the avid quality that really is
necessary to come out with something at
the other end and as he went on he spoke
of humility in the face of an idea
saying the composing enterprise is to
make a pattern which has its own logic
and which cars out this space in the air
in some way that is at least unique to
the event whether or not it sounds like
the composer or not our second speaker
will be Anita Desai who's professor of
writing at MIT in her fiction she
balances idealism and disillusionment
dreams and failures and her prose is
luminous and unflinching she spends a
counterpoint of cultures that grows out
of her own eye for detail that provides
the reader's imagination with an
expansive and comprehensive view in 1994
professor Desai contributed an
introduction to the Turkish embassy
letters of Lady Mary Wortley Montagu who
lived from 1689 to 1762 which is my
period of Reis
her sympathetic description of Lady
Mary's success as a letter writer in a
cross-cultural situation may perhaps and
only may provides some insight into
Desai's own creative process she wrote
in that introduction
Lady Mary proved a traveler of a very
diligent curiosity I like to think that
that's what all artists are our
travelers with a diligent curiosity and
the reason why the embassy letters have
survived the years may be that in
traveling to the east lady mary was able
to break away from the rigid
confinements mental and intellectual as
well as physical of her own society and
showed herself exceptionally open to new
impressions and points of view this
gives her letters and immediacy and
vivacity that remain as fresh as the
mosaics on the ancient monument that she
saw and the eastern gardens that gave
her such delight our final speaker today
will be Louise Glick a professor at
Williams College and in her 1994 book of
essays proofs and theories she writes of
the work of poetry she begins her essay
education of the poet with these words
the fundamental experience of the writer
is helplessness this does not mean to
distinguish writing from being alive it
is to correct the fantasy that creative
work is an ongoing record of the triumph
of volition that the writer is someone
who has the good luck to be able to do
what he or she wishes to do to
confidently and regularly imprint his
being on a sheet of paper but writing is
not the decanting of personality again
the question is whose story and most
writers spend much of their time in
various kinds of torment wanting to
write being unable to write wanting to
write differently being unable to write
differently
in a whole lifetime years are spent
waiting to be claimed by an idea and
remember John Harbison wrote about
accepting an idea even if it's not like
the composer the only real exercise of
will is negative we have toward what we
write the power of veto this afternoon
we will hear from our three panelists in
that order first john Harbison then
Anita Desai then Louise Glick they will
each speak from the table we are going
to have a cozy set up and after each of
after the presentations we will have a
discussion where we will welcome your
participation we urge you to let us know
that you want to participate so we can
get you a microphone please help me to
welcome our three distinguished
panelists for the afternoon colloquium
[Applause]
well it falls to me to begin and I want
first to say that I'm glad to have been
invited particularly in the company of
two fellow artists whose work I have
admired a long time it was a nice
occasion to reread some of the work
though I don't know what it's gonna do
for what I have to say and I I want to
begin with a musical example is
something I suggested to Ellen as a
possible mode of commencement in doing
so I'm mindful of remark quite often
made by my teacher
Roger sessions that discussions of music
without music are essentially akin to
pornography they awaken the appetite but
without any real realization of said
appetite so I'm going to play five
minutes of music from a recent
composition which I chose partly because
it's obvious relationship to our subject
matter how we tell our stories I begin
though with a caution about how
musicians tell their stories because I
am going to play five minutes of an
opera but we don't really musically most
of the time tell our stories with the
aid of words or sequences of events or
any mimetic kind of imitation of nature
but rather we tell our stories in a more
esoteric way through the movement of
harmony through the identity of motives
and melodic ideas through associations
through contrast both large and small
all kinds of storytelling methods which
really are much more the stuff of music
than what we see and hear at the
foreground of an
experience of opera or of anything that
involves the stage so that what you're
going to hear is five minutes of a very
large piece of music a piece of music
which for me is hanging together and
telling its story much more on the
levels of abstraction that I've just
suggested rather than simply the
following along of what is going on in
the piece that is to say the drive of
this narrative is in the notes and in
the relationship between the notes and
it happens to synchronize I hope at the
right places with an action and with a
story and I think an operatic
storyteller hones their skills as much
as anything in becoming very precise
about the notes and about the way that
they influence and affect each other
with that said I'll just tell you what
the little snip of what was I think
somewhat perjorative Lee described as a
vast opera will will be this is from the
beginning of the second act of the Opera
and some I think I can't take the time
to fill those of you know great Gatsby's
plotline though there were two teenagers
reading it next to me on the subway just
the other day and they were discussing
it in terms which I found extremely
discouraging
but I will just say that at this point
Daisy and Gatsby have renewed their five
year old affair she's by then however
married in conveniently enough and in
this second party scene of the Opera Tom
and Daisy show up at a Gatsby party for
the first time and in the scene that
you're going to hear you'll hear what we
we would call first
ambient music that is to say music
played by a band at a party which is so
it's a period flavor though in disguise
the motives and the basic harmonic drive
of the piece are still kept going even
in this music one of the problems of the
piece being movement from ambient music
into the music that I write which is the
substantially most of the music in the
eye that I normally write whatever that
is because as you heard from the thing
Ellen Ellen quoted what I normally write
isn't that clear to me but nevertheless
moving from the ambient music in which
Tom and Daisy are ostensibly introduced
to Gatsby of course he knows her already
and we then get an account by Gatsby his
early life now one of the reasons I
chose this passage is that this account
in this form doesn't occur at all in the
novel it is something which is I thought
important in the Opera to do frontally
it is a stiff dose for people who want
Gatsby's voice and persona to remain
misty and an indistinct and I find the
people who dislike this out for the most
are the ones that remember the book in
the most hazy romantic way and the
friends of the Opera tend to be either
you know rabid Fitzgerald readers and
scholars or people who forgotten the
book almost completely
but at this point Gatsby delivers this
account of Asst of his life which is
mostly phony to Tom to his girlfriend's
husband who is getting his first dose of
Gatsby and who finds him a rather
outlandish figure but at the same time
Daisy occasionally joins in in
suggestive lines in this narrative
dreams off into them in a sense
establishing a connection between them
which is not yet really known to Tom in
fact the action of the scene is the
realization of Tom's jealousy beginning
of jealousy or suspicion about Gatsby
and Daisy and at the end of the
monologue the little very brief account
of Gatton of Gatsby's life you'll hear a
kind of return to the ambient music at
the point when Daisy when Tom says you
renew your old acquaintance with Gatsby
which they've just established and I'll
introduce myself around he already has
his eye on an actress who he then goes
off and dances with and you'll hear the
ambient music returned and at that point
in this in the composition I think
you'll be able to hear in its best
clearest form the kind of transitional
issue between the stuff of the Opera
which is the you know the music in which
I kind of live and work and a synthetic
period of voguing kind of composition
people come out of this piece saying gee
it's great hearing those old songs again
which is kind of flattering because you
know they are old songs that I composed
and and other people come out of the
Opera saying you know he really can't
write melodies so it's wonderful at
least has those old songs which of
course is quite literally impossible
that is if one can compose a melody in
one idiom you can another but of course
this is part of the wonderful process of
sifting which I think all of us up here
on stage know about in terms of the
things we put out there so let's play
the five-minute example and then I'm
going to go on from it to comment a bit
about opera in relationship to other
narrative media because of course in the
adaptation of a novel this is one of the
things that immediately becomes an
important subject to think about and if
back there the level should be up I'll
point up and if it should be down I'll
point down and if it's wonderful I won't
point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the man standing next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
gets me this is quite the place are you
in business you might say so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but part of the Middle West San
Francisco my family died
[Music]
collecting jewels haunting marinating
Pete
trying to forget something very sad
[Music]
I tried hard to die but it
[Music]
my detachment hello
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's the five minutes now what
you heard at the end is the band singer
has come back on now the musicians in
the stage band love the reality thing of
taking a break in that scene which of
course all my musician friends really
enjoy too they actually leave the stage
I don't know what they do in their
offstage but it's it's a kind of a
moment which also helps to define I
think the two musical realms that are
going on here that that the ambient
music and the music that expresses the
characters are both different and linked
by these these common sort of motivic
and harmonic threats it is a very
different thing it's one of about 400
things that are very different about the
adaptation of this novel to have gatsby
actually express frontally this
particular narrative particularly to his
rival is to rival to be in operatic
terms it's very useful in setting up a
kind of pre confrontation which in the
plaza scene will be much intensified it
also serves another purpose which is it
gives a kind of voice to what is in the
novel a very shadowy rumor kind of
texture this is a kind of sideways sort
of thing that a novelist can do which is
much less the province of of the
operatic character I can do things like
that in transitions in orchestral
passages and wordless passages but when
the characters speak they have to back
it up either either in a phony way as
Gatsby does by putting out a lot of
details which are not real or at least
in some way that they are heard by
someone or even in a monologue heard by
themselves and made responsible for
certain kinds of emotions and feelings
directly - with between them in the
audience in Opera we can't choose
with anywhere near the variety of a
novelist or precision the a narrative
voice one of the reasons that I got rid
of Nick in his narrative function is
that this is not something which is in
my experience with Opera a terribly
effective way of hearing and
experiencing an opera through a
character in a novel it can be a very
rewarding journey to be listening to the
voice of a narrator in Opera you're
listening to the voice of the composer
who is narrating this these events and
unless the composer takes those events
in hand in terms of pacing and
essentially deciding what all the
characters say there really isn't enough
focus in terms of where the audience
should be becoming in the audience is
Ian on and everything there is no real
way to shadow things out or to feather
things out so that you almost see them
certainly with a staging you can kind of
almost see a scene but when the music
happens and people sing things they sing
them and one of the problems that I had
of course with presenting Gatsby on
stage is the cherished image of a of a
hero you don't know about and I had to
almost immediately from the very first
thing that he sings established that's
not going to be how it is because this
is an opera which caused many people to
call me with magic bullets from all over
the country you know it's amazing opera
seems to be something that everyone
knows how to fix but one of the things
that I heard is if you just get rid of a
scene where Gatsby is seen consorting
with Wolfsheim then we may be able to
retain our illusions about Gatsby well
yes you will but you won't have
confronted one of the most important
things about this guy which is that he's
also a proto gangster and if you put him
on stage and show him consorting with
Wolfsheim you give body to a very
different character than that nursed by
someone who's read the novel and
filtered out the details they don't want
to deal with that is to say on stage and
in a voice you deal with all the details
the good side of putting people on stage
with voices is that because they sing
there's no such thing as an
unsympathetic sympathetic character if
you're a novelist maybe you want
unsympathetic characters and certainly
in the originals of things that are
adapted to opera the villainous people
the people who are not very nice are
able to be much more not nice than they
are in opera one of the things I liked
about this quality in Gatsby well when I
started this project my mother called up
she said you're writing an opera on a
subject which doesn't have a single
sympathetic character I said well yes
but they're gonna sing and and that will
change the way they're perceived and
also operatic Lee I did change them I
made Daisy much more a kind of romance
novel reading person with a really at
the very least kind of histrionic side
and and even Wolfsheim because he sings
he has very rounded people with voices
present somehow dimensions to you that
because of the sound of the voice they
don't have you know the any other medium
I always think of Rigoletto as my
favorite example of this there's a
villain in there named spyfu chilly well
this guy is a contract killer and he
does nothing in the Opera but kill
people and set them up to be killed and
yet the way he is set by Verdi with this
in markable sort of oral image that he
creates for this guy he's fascinating he
he lives in a way that that he couldn't
possibly if he was not surrounded by
this particular sonic world that he
evolved his voice and his instruments
and this is the the narrative faculty in
Opera which i think is is something that
opera composes relish and have to take
hold of and it I think dictates most of
the adaptation alysha's that come up
Tchaikovsky and Eugene Onegin made
similar responses when people said hey
you got rid of all
all the good things about that that
wonderful Pushkin poem all the irony all
the shadowy parts all the ambiguities he
said well of course it's an opera they
have to be different and they are so
radically different there that anyone
who loves that literary property too
much is not never gonna like that opera
I wanted to say a little bit about the
difference between what we do as
composers in in theatre and what a
dramatist does because I worked with a
stage director in this project who whose
experience was initially as an actor on
stage and as a stage director for very
many years with the Hartford stage and
he said that the biggest change for him
coming into the Opera Theatre is that we
composers have notated all of our
pacings and as a result the
decision-making process for the director
is vastly limited that's to say when
things happen is not in the control of
the stage director and he said one of
the things that he envies is that when
he was as a theater director an actor
would suddenly pause for a minute and a
half before a line and he would have a
heart attack in the back of the theaters
and why where did that come from he's
ruined my pacing well if we've written
just two beats rest in that spot that's
not going to happen and beyond that even
the pace at which the line is delivered
the actual pulse of the line since we
have things like the metronome which is
a thing that gives tempo signals to a
conductor and we have all kinds of very
very refined notational procedures the
pacing of a line is under a kind of
control for musician that that no other
dramatist
and this I think includes novelists and
poets can control I've often thought
about novelists as I'm reading a novel
and I'm putting it down at some
arbitrary point you know and I may be in
the middle of a chapter and I may be
planning to pick it up in five days and
I'm thinking what a tough situation for
them because at least in my situation as
a composer they may be bored they may
wish they could leave the theater maybe
sometimes
they will but under most circumstances
they have to sit there for the pacing
and the unfolding that I've decided they
can't put it down
I guess that are listening on a CD at
home they can but that's not the kind of
listeners I'm writing for anyway but in
the live performance they're there and
they are experiencing the thing more or
less the way that it was planned the
hitch is of course that to put on an
opera like the one you just heard a
snatch of takes to two hundred people
and many of them in collaborations of
tremendous significance even right down
to the people who move the things onto
the stage and those 200 people modify
that precision of intent to almost as
great a factor as their number and that
is the sort of the contrary example to
the to the control of pacing and the
ability to keep you right there in the
theater I want to say just in concluding
a little something about text and what
operatic text is there's a very great
essay by an Italian composer Luigi dalla
piccola about operatic text in which he
and actually this is actually a widely
held view in in this sort of Italian
operatic theory world Montana has
written about this to most of the
Italians agree that great poetry
intricate lyric poetry is the worst
thing for an opera text in fact they
hold up the melodramatic melody Ramat ex
of middle Verdi as the kind of ideal
operatic text because of the plainness
of the lines the apprehend ability of
the sentiment the conciseness of the
thought and opera is in general not a
place where great lyric poetry comes to
roost
there are reasons for that partly that
we can't double back and we parse a line
or try to reconstruct a line in our
minds the way we can when we read a poem
or the way we can when were at a song
recital and we have a text in front of
us and someone is singing a poem by
Heine or some great poet because
composers do set really great poems
sometimes against the objections of the
poets but we do it anyway that's an
arena where the the rethought or the the
puzzling out which I think is very
important to the experience of some
experience of reading their poetry is
possible in the Opera House its past and
if it doesn't make its mark if it
doesn't hit it doesn't get another
chance we move the past and we need in
the Opera House a immediacy of statement
if it has poetic value it's a bonus but
the operatic text that I love most in a
literary sense are not really the ones
that I love most as opera texts the WH
Auden did a very beautiful text for
Stravinsky in the race progress but I
enjoy it most when I can sit with it as
lyric poetry on my own time and prepare
really really for many minutes ahead and
then feel that I have a fighting chance
of really absorbing what is really then
a dual set of sensations that is the
sensation of a composer working at the
highest level at the same time that a
poet is working at a very high level and
it's in the theatre and it's gone by and
you can't stop it so that the medium the
poetic medium of Opera is a somewhat
adapted kind and the story has to be
told and it has to be told with
regrettably very very ruthless plainness
I think those are the places I wanted to
be I wrote it out at home and it was
only five minutes so I think there's
much better do it in this form and I
will now sit back
[Applause]
[Music]
being the novelist here I get to answer
the question how to artists tell their
stories at the most basic level of all
but in answering it I found I couldn't
without drawing upon the other arts to
an extent that surprised me for most of
my life I have lived and I wrote in
India and the analog of the writing life
that seemed to me the most apt was
Virginia woods description of the writer
I figure in an attitude of contemplation
like a fisherwoman sitting on the bank
of a lake with a fishing rod held over
its water she was not thinking she was
not reasoning she was not constructing a
plot she was letting her imagination
down into the depths of her
consciousness while she sat above
holding on by a thin but necessary that
thread of reason she was letting her
imagination sweep unchecked round every
nook and cranny of the world that lies
submerged in a sub in our unconscious
being now of course I knew that what
made me stare into the water are upon
our in a kind of trance was the belief a
writer fisherwoman must have that in
that lake that lurks a fish a certain
stubbornness is required even a defiant
stubbornness that seems to others to
border on the unreasonable yet these
ripples or glimpses of the cruising fin
are there for everyone to see who cares
to they are what is called reality or
life or the world the one tenth visible
section of what lies within that lake
what sets the writer fishable
woman apart is the obsession with the
belief that this is only the tip of the
truth
the truth is the 9/10 sections of
below the surface and that is the
writers prey even the fiction writers
and writing is a way to plunge below the
surface to discover and explore what
lies submerged in the dark water below
then make that region a more lucid more
brilliant more explicable reflection of
the visible world and visible lives in
this persuade the writer has to
cultivate the art of patience so as to
make possible what Ted use called the
stirrings of a new poem in your mind
then the outline the mass and color and
clean final form of it the unique living
reality of it in the midst of general
lifelessness
apart from patience one requires some
equipment in all my Indian ears I
believe these two consist of three items
silence secrecy and cunning and I never
heard never heard of a writing course or
a writer's workshop writing in solitude
and secrecy afraid really that the
assaults of life would come to close and
damage the web that I was so nervous Lee
spinning i believed with bruce that real
books must be children not of broad
daylight and small talk but of darkness
and silence with real key what is needed
is in the end simply this solitude great
inner solitude and with walter Delamere
again and again he must stand back from
the press and habit of convention he
must keep recapturing solitude practice
this long enough the moment comes that
TS Eliot called a sudden lifting of the
burden of anxiety and fear which presses
upon our daily life so steadily that
were unaware of it
some obstructionist momentarily whisked
away the accompanying feeling is a
sudden relief
from an intolerable burden I interpret
this moment as the one when one has
chosen the elements of one's next work
the painter facing a blank canvas with
paint brush in hand has decided where to
make the first stroke from which all the
rest will follow the composer has chosen
a note from which the series of notes
will rise the writer has sensed the
vision that has been courted and now
drawn the outline its map and the moment
comes to step into it to explore this
territory that it encloses and so one
discovers rivers valleys mountain ranges
when had not suspected the pen draws
them on paper lines appear lines made up
of words and at this stage the writer's
pursued by fear fear that one will not
find the words to match it that the
words available to one have been used to
the point of being worn out that they no
longer have the pristine quality
required but that is what must be
achieved so that one can say with Karl
Kraus my language is the universal hoe
whom I have made into a virgin that was
the writing life as I knew it in all my
Indian years one filled with reflection
and contemplation and when I first came
to the United States and began to teach
in order to earn a living
I found myself overthrowing every one of
these beliefs dragging out into the open
in my writing classes what I had always
hidden away with instinctive secrecy it
required a ruthless procedure of
criticism largely self-criticism which I
learned was an indispensable part of the
creative act but it also made me feel I
was doing violence to my past self
I felt as exposed and vulnerable as a
turtle that's lost its shell I
fear dad left India and my Indian self
so far behind that I had never recovered
them so it was a total surprise to me
when I found myself writing again and
writing what's more about India again
perhaps I was trying to recover that old
shelter the old refuge by drawing upon
that familiar world again here's a scene
from the Indian section of my novel
fasting feasting on the veranda
overlooking the garden the drive and the
gate they sit together on the creaking
sofa swing suspended from its iron frame
dangling their legs so that the slippers
on their feet hang loose before them a
low round table is covered with a faded
cloth embroidered in the center with
flowers behind them a pedestal fan broke
blows warm air at the backs of their
necks and heads the cane mats which hang
from the arches of the veranda to keep
out the Sun and dust I rolled up now
bidden set upon the rolls conversing
tenderly picking a ticks fluttering
pigeon droppings splattered the stone
tiles below and feathers folk float top
idli through the air
the parents said rhythmically swinging
back and forth they could be asleep
dozing the eyes are hooded but sometimes
they speak we're having fritters for tea
today
will that be enough or do you want
sweets as well yes yes yes there must be
sweets must be sweets to tell cook to
cook it once
uma uma uma master cook a Yuma button
uma comes to the door where she stands
fretting why are you shouting going to
cook but you just told me to do up the
parcel so it's ready when justice that
son comes to take it I'm tying it up now
oh yes yes yes make up the parcel must
be ready must be
when justice that Sun comes what are we
sending our own
what are we sending him t Shawn Shawn
Shawn yes the shawl mama bought mama
bought mama bought my twists her
shoulders and impatience that brown
shawl mama bought for Arun Papa brown
shawl yes papa in case Arun is cold in
America let me go and finish packing it
now it won't be ready when justice that
son comes then we'll have to send it by
post post post no no no no very costly
too costly no point in that if justice
that son is going to America get the
parcel ready for him to take get it
ready Yuma first go and tell Kakuma tell
cook fritters won't be enough Papa wants
sweets sweets also yes must be sweets
then come back and take dictation take
down a letter for Arun just as that son
can take it with him now you want me to
write a letter when I am busy packing a
parcel for 100 parcel for our own yes
yes yes make up the parcel it must be
ready ready for justice that uma
flounces of her gray hair frazzled a
myopic eyes glaring behind her
spectacles muttering under her breath
the parents momentarily agitated upon
their swing by the sudden invasion of
ideas sweets parcel letters sweets
settled back to their slow rhythmic
swinging they look out upon the
shimmering heat of the afternoon as if
the tray with tea with sweets with
fritters will materialize and come
swimming out of it to the rescue with
increasing impatience they swing and
swing
but while writing down a scene which is
so well-known to me that it's imprinted
on my skin and my eyes there were also
these scenes from my new American life
pressing in on me demanding my attention
demanding to be addressed if only from
the point of view of a stranger and a
foreigner so I read a scene from the
second Americans section of the book
fasting feasting which follows our own
in his trials it is summer Aaron makes
his way slowly through the abundant
green of Edge Hill as if he were moving
cautiously through massed waves of water
under which unknown objects lurked
greenness hangs drips and sways from
every branch and twig in front in the
surging luxuriant of July in such
profusion the houses seemed lost
stranded as they might have been when
this was primeval forests white
clapboard is the most prominent but
their houses painted dark with red oxide
some with a military gray with white
trim these touches of color seem both
brave and forlorn picture-book dreams
pitted against the wilderness without
conviction outside many of them the
starred and striped American flags lies
on a post with all the bravado of a new
frontier in direct contradiction they
are the more domestic signs of
habitation that implies settlement by
generations rubber paddling pools left
outside go-karts and skateboards garden
furniture and garden statuary pink
plastic flamingos poised beside the
birdbath spotted years or hatted gnomes
crouched amongst the rhododendrons like
decoys set out by homesteaders conveying
some message to the threatening
hinterland
Aaron keeps his chin Lord as nervous as
someone venturing alone across the
border
his eyes glancing from side to side into
the windows
none of them are curtain many are large
he can look directly at the kitchen
sinks the pots of flowering busy
Lizzie's the lamps the dangling glass
decorations there's so many objects so
rarely any people talking his chain into
a scholar he ponders these omens and
indicators he turns into bayberry Lane
and walks past more trimmed lawns down
the slope to the last house on the hill
here to a red and white blue flag flies
upon its pole its rope slack in the
summer stillness the mailbox holding its
measure of junk mail too voluminous to
merit collection here to the big picture
windows are lit the rooms empty like
state sets before the play begins is
there or is there not to be a play he
walks around to the side of the house
and sees mrs. Patton is there
she's unpacking several large brown
paper grocery bags placing cartons and
containers on the counter slowly
thoughtfully putting away each item
after several minutes of holding and
considering it Arun stands watching her
purse her lips an occasionally touch her
mouth with a plump freckled hand as she
bends to put away the cat food or open
the refrigerator and stack frozen cans
into its Eisley illuminated spaces now
she stops a can of plum tomatoes in her
hand and doesn't know what to do next
she's frozen with a stricken look on her
face like an actress who's forgotten her
lines although at the very heart of this
domestic scene
she seems lost when you'll agree that
these are two very disparate fragments
of experience
and looking at them I realize my world
had really been shattered into bits now
I had to go down on my knees and sort
out the fragments put them together
again but in a new design since they
didn't belong to each other they belong
to different worlds but hadn't Elliott
told me taught me that the writers mind
is a receptacle for seeing and storing
up numberless feelings phrases images
which remain there until all the
particles can unite to form a new
compound and to satisfy that need to
unite I sifted through the material to
find the motifs that ran through them
and in the final scene of the book I
draw them all together again it's the
end of the summer Arun has packed his
belongings into the blue leather right
suitcase he's brought with him he's
puzzling over what to do with the parcel
that's arrived from India only this
morning with its innumerable wrappings
of brown paper and string each bearing
the mark of his sister's clumsy and
impatient kare-kare providentially
catching him at the patterns before he
moves out and back to the campus the
parcel contains a packet of tea and a
brown wool shawl both calculated to help
him through the coming winter
what hadn't been calculated that he
hasn't the extra space for them in the
suitcase he picks up the box of tea in
one hand the folded shawl in the other
one is heavy the other light one's hard
the other soft a lopsided gift he holds
them trying to find the balance he goes
downstairs to find mrs. baton the tea in
one hand the shawl in the other mrs.
Burton no longer lies in the yard Cyn
sunbathing the days are warm and still
with a silvery sheen but she seems to
have taken an aversion to the light even
to the outdoors
she no longer spends much time in the
kitchen either she is stopped offering
to take her own shopping
although the kitchen is drastically
depleted only remains left at the
bottoms of jars and bottles she traces
now in skirts and long-sleeved blouses
she has voiced a tentative interest in
traditional medicine she talks of taking
a course at the leisure activity center
in yoga or astrology the catalogues
pamphlets and leaflets lying drifts
around her now as she sits on the porch
quite still on an upright chair she's
holding an acupuncture chart on her lap
but is staring over the top of it
through the Y's screen at the yard which
is empty except for the cat carefully
stalking a moth in a bed of dead and
wilted flowers everything in that scene
looks fatigued or spent or faded our own
goes quietly up to her to quietly
because she gives us start and clutches
her neck and fright I'm sorry our own
apologizes clearing a frog in his throat
I have brought you some presents
I'm leaving now mrs. batten leaving now
she repeats bewildered the semester
starts tomorrow he reminds her I've got
to go back to the dome I'm packed oh
dear she says mildly please take these
things my parents sent them for you he
lies hoping they'll never guess what
happened to their gifts and hands at the
box of tea which she takes with a polite
murmur of surprise and turns over and
her hands
studying the label with a habitual
attention that she gives to consumer
products and she queries hopefully is it
over Iren opens out the brown shawl he
takes out the feet he shakes out the
falls arranged is it carefully about her
shoulders and aroma arises from it
of another land muddy grassy smokey
ashen it swamps him like a river like a
fire she looks at him then at the wolf
stuff on her shoulders in an in
comprehension she picks at a fold of it
and sniffs and slowly her face spreads
into a flash of wonder why Arun she
stammers this is beautiful thank you she
repeats thank you and puts a hand to her
neck to hold the ends of the shawl
together he withdraws quietly going up
to collect his suitcase then finding his
way back out by the kitchen door leaving
us sitting on the porch with the box of
tea on her knees and the shawl round her
shoulders well with that book was done
and I was left saying as I always do oh
no that's not what I meant
and so you begin spinning the next one
[Applause]
it's much nicer to listen it seems very
odd to be here
I feel as I have never in my life told a
story except the most rudimentary and
repeating human stories birth love loss
death rebirth I suppose you would I
would have thought that what would
preoccupy a poet would be the world of
sensation but this isn't true either I
think that what tends to interest me is
dilemma the investigation of dilemma or
psychological predicament of some kind
and the danger of course is of the work
by virtue of its obsessive nature and
rudimentary quality would be repetitious
the task of the artist is to keep the
obsessions from being boring
first to the artists I do this because
it's thrilling
I mean I'm mostly not doing it but when
I am doing it it's very exciting and
it's exciting because of a sensation of
novelty and exploration what I like is
the sense that I have heard a new tone
and it will take me on a voyage and I
have no idea where you begin with that
tone the best analogy I can make and
obviously it's imagined because I can't
reconstruct the experience of the infant
and the cradle but it seems to me likely
that a small child listening to
conversations in the next room before
knowing language will be able to infer
from the rhythms the rising and falling
of the parents voices some
and the task of the infant is to
discover the meaning of the words that
feel the meaning of the rhythms the task
of the poet is the same you hear a
rhythmic structure or a line of phrases
visited on you it's nonsense
usually it's a particle it's a fragment
but you sense it's resonances and it
torments you until you can find for that
line the context that will allow it to
speak I thought what I would do
Ellen said we were to have fun I thought
we'll just chat here sort of like Plato
but I see we can't quite do that
so I'll read three poems from very
different periods of my life that
automatically identical and I think in
manner very different I can point out
even in the first and earliest a
strategy on which I came to depend a
problem is that if you're not telling
stories how can you achieve a sense on
the page of the of drama and I think you
can do so by changing course in the
middle of the journey by calling it to
question the premise on which the poem
begins by arguing within within it so
that it essentially you have a
multiplicity of voices speaking certain
forms of a resolution not leaving things
out which always well I I don't do that
but
by setting in motion a world of
questions and ideas that cannot simply
be resolved I'm obliged because of this
situation to read these poems to you I I
make a lot of my living doing poetry
readings and I have never liked the form
I I first of all I don't like the way my
voice necessarily substitutes for the
voice that I hear on the page people
will come up after a reading and say ah
now I know how you mean the poem to
sound and I say no you don't you will
only know it if you read it and
oftentimes there's a terrible
discrepancy between the palette of which
my instrument is capable and what seems
to me the sound I have heard and
sometimes when you read work for the
first time and are struck by that you're
grief-stricken at the inappropriateness
of of the sound that came out of your
mouth in any case I dislike reading
principally because it turns a poem into
it a relentlessly sequential experience
each line erased by the line that
follows it this is not what happens when
you read it on the page it's small
enough so that it can be held in the
mind and it's resonances and echoes
registered so that the moment of reading
contains that in dense
Anette the first poem I'll read was
written when I was about 20 it's called
cottonmouth country and it was a piece
of my
now almost entirely repudiated first
book I try to cultivate toward this book
a kind of tenderness but that's the best
that I can do but there are poems in it
of which I'm still proud I would hardly
read this otherwise cottonmouth country
fishbones walked the waves off Hatteras
and there were other signs that death
would us by water would us by land among
the pines and uncurled cottonmouth that
rolled on Moss weird in the polluted air
birth not death is the hard loss I know
I also left a skin there none of this
happened as fact I passed through Cape
Hatteras I thought what a beautiful
sound that word is I did see a snake but
the poem came from some other nest of
memories and ideas and the
preoccupations I began by talking about
this is a fairly rudimentary and
recurring human experience the
experience of being forced to be born
again to change that would be the other
word for it that's the word most people
use the next poem that treats of those
same themes was written many many many
years later and tonally utterly
different and yet it's the same
experience this is from a book called
the wild iris 1991 I think the poem was
written
that first pain was Oh late 60s 70s
early this is the title poem of the book
and the opening lines were the lines
with which this book began I hadn't
written a word for two years that's not
for me uncommon and increasingly I find
that I write in kind of seizures which
sounds exciting it sounds like
possession it sounds like the visitation
of the muse but in fact it's it's very
complicated because there's no feeling
of agency so that when you finish you
have no sense that you've actually
written the work this is not to say that
you think the muse read it what it is to
say is that you fear you have stolen it
that you have remembered it that it's
somebody else's and you've appropriated
it so you start sending these poems that
were written suddenly three for a day to
your friends asking if they recognize
any of their lines but you can't send
them to everybody in the world and it is
it's rather it's frightening and I find
having now written three books like this
I feel I wish to be again the studious
the endeavour ring maker of course I I'm
sure that my nostalgia for that form has
not sufficient memory of the ordeals of
that form anyway this is a book that was
written very quickly but the first lines
of this poem I had in my head for two
years but I didn't know what they meant
and I didn't know who said them in
reference to what this was not the first
poem of the book written but after I had
written a cluster of these flower poems
I thought this is where this is where
those words come from this is who speaks
them
this book is organized as three kinds of
voices a human voice the poems spoken by
the human voice are called either
Vespers or mountains voices of the earth
the poems that represent such voices
bear flower names and whatever is not
included in those other two whatever
name you want to give it the celestial
then not human the wild iris at the end
of my suffering there was a door
hear me out that which you call death
I remember overhead noises branches of
the pine shifting then nothing the
week's Sun flickered over the dry
surface it is terrible to survive as
consciousness buried in the dark earth
then it was over that which you fear
being a soul and unable to speak ending
abruptly the stiff earth bending a
little and what I took to be birds
darting in low shrubs you who do not
remember passage from the other world I
tell you I could speak again
whatever returns from oblivion returns
to find a voice from the center of my
life came a great fountain deep blue
shadows on a Jersey water well I was
grateful to be writing again and that's
what that's about but like cottonmouth
country it's a poem
an immense transition the transition
from silence to speech from drifting
buried unconscious to conscious speaking
in cottonmouth country its birth not
death is the hard loss the last poem
I'll read of this type though I could
probably read 50 is the last poem in my
most recent book I have a new one coming
out in April and the poem is anomalous
within the book it was the first one
written and when I wrote it I thought oh
damn I can't write anymore I can only
write these insouciant merry little
poems in the book it works a different
way but you will hear it without the
book and so it will be an insouciant
merry little poem about rebirth that
begins this one is much more grounded in
[Music]
social experience experience of divorce
and relocation and it uses the book uses
a lot of local footage it's a very
cambridge book
Vita Nova in the splitting up dream we
were fighting over who would keep the
dog blizzard you tell me what that name
means he was a cross between something
big and fluffy and a dachshund does this
have to be the male and female genitalia
poor blizzard why was he a dog he barely
touched the hummus in his dog food dish
then there was something else a sound
like gravel being moved or sand the
sands of time then it was Erica with her
maracas like the sands of time
personified who will explain this to the
dog blizzard daddy needs you daddy's
heart is empty not because he's leaving
mommy
but because the kind of love he wants
mommy doesn't have mommies too ironic
mommy wouldn't do the rumba in the
driveway or is this wrong supposing I'm
the dog as in my child self unconsolable
because completely pre verbal with
anorexia Oh Blizzard be a brave dog this
is all material you'll wake up in a
different world you will eat again you
will grow up into a poet life is very
weird no matter how it ends very filled
with dreams never will I forget your
face your frantic human eyes swollen
with tears I thought my life was over
and my heart was broken then I moved to
Cambridge
[Applause]
we are now open for questions and there
are microphones on both sides so if use
the podium yes you can also go over here
we have disdained it but you are welcome
to it Harvison I wonder if you could
articulate how you approach writing
music that has no extra musical elements
that you know it's pure pure music
exactly the way I work when I'm with
words or with theatrical action there's
what sets it in motion for me is is a
what I would call a musical thought so
it's not a gear shift of course my view
of opera and in fact song composition is
that they are first of all pieces of
music and then they have to do with
other things and in that view I find
myself somewhat out of phase at least
with some elements of the Opera
community who evaluate opera more on the
basis of the libretto or perhaps even of
the sequence of events but but for me
music is a little bit as described by
Anita and Louise it's it's a fragment
that you're haunted by and you have to
find some day a place for it and if
writing a big piece of say theatrical
music you have a someplace that you
store those things until they start to
make sense but they make sense I think
first as a musical train of thought as I
said that you then hope can be
applicable to to a dramatic action may I
ask a question yes I have to I am
curious John to know what draws you
to a text because to embark on an opera
is to invest an enormous amount of time
in a project you can't I suppose here a
cluster of notes and think gatsby boy
what happens no it really is that is it
like that yeah because it's very greedy
in the sense that any setting or
anything dealing with the text is
because I'm getting the gift of some
musical associations and and the and the
working out of a libretto for Gatsby was
just here the sections I can find music
for and what dropped out was what I
didn't have music for him and and really
that's a bit the same with setting a
song to a poem if if the music seems to
be coming along and very often the poem
is a vehicle to write a piece of music
that I wanted to write and that you know
can then you know work together with the
poem to be a little more intelligible
with the help of the poem right but but
it really isn't it isn't a sense of this
will be a good opera it's more or this
will be a good poem to set to music it's
more that you can't get rid of a kind of
an association between some music and
some substance you know that is not is
not notes
my question is a distant echo of the
previous session namely about language
in writing and creative writing and I
have a question was two parts which I
would like to illustrate that there will
be totally trivial meaning this may be
different meaning is anyway but if one
part has to do with style versus content
and the other writing in one's native
language versus not to illustrate the
first if we look at the writing of
Edison of Tatler
and steel which talk to Johnson
according to boss will recommended as
the one with the best English styles his
stories of Roger de Coverley and not
very great depths as for example
Immanuel Kant
but Kant writes in a style which is very
very difficult to read and not very
appealing even as important things to
say
so does paul of tarsus better now st.
paul except some parts of latitude
currently still 2 corinthians he people
tell me his Greek is atrocious yeah his
first two languages transition the
second question second part the two
languages a Hebrew and Aramaic so Greek
he does know Greek but this impact as
creator of Christendom was tremendous
let me move to the second part namely
native versus not native language there
are people who write excellently in the
language was not the first language like
Isaiah Berlin was born in Riga in in
Russia nor ever Hoffman who's this
university but the essay is not creative
writers creative writers I can think
only of Conrad and Nabokov who wrote
good English non the book of at the end
of Lolita PostScript says in spite of
all success maybe it was tongue-in-cheek
his English was not what the Russian
language would do for him now Conrad I
don't know this obviously he learned
English somewhat and his childhood but
not but it was not his first language
and finally a question the first one was
really to Louise a Glick apart the
question of the pre verbal laugh
if language is your childhood language
the second part is the foreign writers I
think the Indian write is a special case
because many of them example a suitable
boy are really bilingual so it's English
maybe baby not their second language
tutor repeat to sum it up the question
of first language versus second and
style versus content and importance of
style irrespective what the content is
would like to start I don't know how to
start so I don't I don't quite know
what's being asked do you see a
difference between style and content do
you see a distinction between style and
content I suppose if you write if you're
if you're studying a piece of work and
writing an essay about it you can
isolate its content but it's content is
put on the page with a certain choice of
words that determines the way that
context content is understood content is
tone the tone toward the material I I
don't know where that fissure between
them lies confidently enough to
elaborate it I mean our questioner is
posing the idea as I understood it of
works that are very good in style even
models of good style where the content
is superficial at best and yes yes and
then the opposite well I think if
there's if there's glorious style and
spiritual deficit it won't be memorable
I don't know I think of I think one
rights the language one reads and
there's this whole world of literature
for us to dip into and what what write
writers do what artists do is constantly
amalgamate put together what I would
love to do is make a language up of all
the languages I hear I know use whatever
fragments come to my mind at any given
moment and make up this patchwork which
I live with I know it wouldn't have any
meaning for my readers I can't do that
but that's what I try to move towards
maybe I can only use tones and rhythms
to differentiate the languages but the
idea is one of inclusion not of
exclusion that seems to fit in so well
with the previous panel another question
I have a comment with John Harbison
about your point that the singing
somehow took away from the negative
connotations of the bootlegger gangster
and Gatsby and I was led to think about
whether singing and opera is all that
special
for example hmm you take a monster like
a Yago and it's not just that he sings
but that they were that he's originally
can say conceived in Shakespearean
poetry which immediately gives him a
very different quality and then if you
transfer that back to Gatsby I mean the
Gatsby we know
speaks Fitzgerald poetry I mean no
gangster ever said alright her voice is
full of money or it was just personal or
any of those wonderful lines of Nazis
he's he's saved from his gangster hood
in a sense by the art of Fitzgerald and
that this raises the whole larger
question that I used to have when I
taught literature and students wanted to
talk about the possibility of a truly
pessimistic or nihilistic work and that
it's almost impossible to have such a
work of art because the the triumph of
the art is an affirmation that negates a
true negative view of life you really
can't have a great work of art that
doesn't save itself by virtue of the
artists achievement of form and closure
from negativism and I so I wonder
whether operas all that different when
just the fact that you sing Gatsby's
voice he's already conceived in a in a
poetic fashion I guess that's a question
of how we perceive it up opera composers
tend to work very pragmatically I think
to the advantage of what they're doing
and in the case of Iago people have
fought for years about whether boy told
transgressed against Shakespeare by
introducing Iago with the so called
credo which is a very Italian eight and
extremely loose precis of some of the
issues that he brings up in the
Shakespeare play but couched in to my
mind such an incredibly over dynamized
the form that anyone who is concerned
say about the transfer ought to be by
that time kind of uneasy about how much
has to change I think to deal with the
difference of the medium I think once
you hold a note for a couple of seconds
you have absolutely crucially chain
the nature of the medium of expression
and opera is if anything about people
holding syllables emphasizing them
putting a number of syllables honor to
give a note all the things that to me
are the the transformatory qualities of
singing as opposed to speech and thus an
art of a very different nature I wasn't
really dealing with content or whether
the nature of the poetry couldn't be in
some way preserved or whether a
pessimistic work could be written in one
or another medium I was really dealing
with just the physical production of
sound no and I think my response to that
which was somewhat facetious but also
quite serious was that once the
inevitable distortions and expressive
heightening
take place these characters are
automatically not the characters we knew
and perhaps loved to or or whatever
however react them to the night into the
in the novel they they have taken on a
completely different mode of
communication with their audience and
thus anyone who's looking for parallels
is going to be disappointed the exact
parallels another question is the mic
here we have sorry Irving seconds if you
can all right we have someone in the
back first okay okay the title the Vita
Nova reminds me down to Aguirre detail
poet and so my question is is there an
evolution which are the major step in
which the way ancient poets pixel spoke
about human nature evolved into more
than there is way to speak about it well
this is Latin
it's not Italian and it though obviously
it calls up Dante and there there are
little Dante resonances in the book the
phrase existed before he made it so well
known is your question has there been an
evolution in human feeling no I mean we
are speak about the way in which poets
speak about in which people tell stories
so our major step major is there an
evolution I mean from the pasture now in
the way people actually tell stories
well there are shifts and what the taste
of a particular time fancies obviously
and there's a sense that certain ground
has been covered by great masters which
were you to advance upon it would
involve your writing work that's going
to be held up beside there's I don't
think that you should necessarily refuse
to do this but I think you have to be
alert to the fact that that comparison
will be made
I think that can ask historical
conditions change and our concerns
change and the mode of being human
changes I mean just the the idea of the
celestial now of the divine is very
different we are not commonly a people
capable of the kind of automatic faith
that was a condition of life centuries
ago this is a change but it means that
the great subjects we're all still going
to die there are still our subjects I
don't know how else to answer you I want
to make some comments that under
underline some of the things that John
was saying in relationship to one thing
in particular that Miss glueck was and
said that reading your poems is a very
different kind of thing I mean
presenting your poems by a reading is
very different from an ordinary person
reading the poems on the page and I was
very much impressed with your reasoning
which was that the poems on the page
have a resonance that arise from the
fact that somebody is reading and
getting into the mood of the rhythm and
I think that is very significant in
terms of what John was saying also that
we in our ordinary thinking we love love
too much together as if in fact the
question asked by this panel what is it
that poets do what is it that to how
people narrate but in a sense the poets
and and the composers aren't doing it
it's the art form the art form of a poem
on a page is very different from the art
form of a poetic reading which is
already theatrical the art form of
poetry or literature is very different
from an operatic use
of it so we talked about setting
Shakespeare to music but Shakespeare is
not set to music he he simply a goat or
an opportunity that the composer has to
use in any way that is appropriate to
his very different kind of art form and
Iago is a good example because Verdi's
Iago is very very different
Shakespeare's Yago and has to be
evaluated in terms of the capacity of
opera of operatic music as opposed to
the capacity of a theatrical performance
so that in a sense what one should be
asking would be the opposite kind of
question how is it that these great
varieties of communications of feeling
emotion ideas occurs through the
different kinds of art forms each of
which have their own techniques their
own access to a relevant meaning which
is based upon that technique which has
to show itself through the technique and
can can communicate with audiences who
are sufficiently school to be able to
appreciate what is possible in whatever
medium is being used by the artist or
whatever medium has taken over the
artist instead of starting the other way
around as if artists are independent of
their meeting yeah we need to take a
shot at this is there anything anyone
would like to respond to this side road
sure it's a question it's a comment all
right we can move on it is your comments
that can be questioned they can be
questioned yes yes do you want to pass
the microphone down and someone we need
them is there another microphone out
here somewhere okay
let's pass this up to you when we finish
here all right some artists exist just
as independent entities and some exist
within universities as you all do I'm
just interested in
how being educators has affected your
work as artists if at all well speaking
for myself because I mentioned working
with students and writers workshops and
groups I can say that it forces one to
be much more analytical I think one is
critical in the act of writing composing
whatever that critical faculty is always
alert and watching over one's shoulder
what one is doing but I think artists
very often fear to analyze certainly in
the process of creating piece of work I
think analysis for us always follows it
never precedes and when you go into a
classroom you find the order of things
sometimes reversed and it's something
very difficult to get used to actually I
love it I love to teach and I feared
beginning to teach because I was afraid
that my enviousness of talent in if it
if I were exposed to it in a period when
I wasn't writing would be such that I
would give bad advice
but that turned out not to be true what
I discovered amazingly was that the
actually I think I analyzed all the time
it's why I hardly ever leave my house
but I think that I discovered that when
I wasn't working the pieces of my mind
that had that needed to be used in my
own work were being used they were being
fueled by the attempt to articulate what
about a student poem which was still
malleable kept it from being memorable
why was it not a memorable work and
could one say where and for what reason
it faltered and then since the act of
diagnosis is actually pretty simple
could one suggest alternative strategies
that would transform this still shifting
work into something stable and resonant
and I couldn't I began to teach when I
was about 28 and I count on it I mean
there are times when I I think I cannot
commute one more time but I like being
in the classroom I like looking at poems
my students have written and figuring
them out and I like being obliged when I
teach literature to prepare myself for
the questions of a student body that's
quite brilliant it's terrifying but I I
like it I need it I need an external
structure of obligation
well since in music we deal with a kind
of different audience from the lyric
poetry audience and people who read
novels that is to say they're in the
room
responding buying tickets and applauding
or not the one of the things that
teaching has focused for me it sort of
narrows down a lot of what I think about
in all the teaching and I do that in
music we we have the task of trying to
get less experienced positions to
balance between what I would think of as
their inner ear and their outer ear that
is the inner ear that conceives
interesting adventurous things perhaps
and structurally ambitious things and
the outer ear that that deals with how
it goes out and how its received way far
in the back rows and what how it
registers to other people and in recent
times I think because we are an art that
exists though it's a small public
relative rock it's it's a real public we
exist in a commercial world the outer
ear has begun to be very over emphasized
I think and that it's part of what I try
to do now as a teacher is to emphasize
the other side to a great degree that
that is that the art if it's to continue
to develop needs to still reside in the
speculative as well as the commercial
and I know Anita has to sell or perhaps
doesn't have to but may be willing to
sell a lot of copies of her books but
she doesn't actually have to go on stage
with them or coach people how to
interpret them or in fact persuade
people to to speak them correctly and
part of what we train musicians to do is
all of those things and it just helped
me to define a relationship to that
practical world which I I think is very
valuable
I heard at least one or two of you
mentioned truth in describing your
telling of stories and so I'm wondering
whether your role here and pursuing your
aesthetic in group if that's what you
would call it in an institution full of
scientific inquiry whether you have
broadened in whether you your growth
your understanding of scientific inquiry
has been enriched by your aesthetic
inquiry and vice versa well whether you
can help us perhaps with more
understanding of the relationship
between your kinds of search for truth
and the scientists or the mathematicians
search for truth I write fiction which
sounds the furthest of oil from truth
but it seems to me that when you're
writing fiction it really frees you in
your exploration of truth one doesn't
need to adhere to any particular
category restrict oneself one is free in
one's exploration but that is what one
is searching certainly do to represent I
just respond on a very practical or a
level about teaching at this institution
we get a kind of volunteer personality
in the arts someone who accepts the idea
that you have to do a lot of work to
make something and that's kind of an
institute wide assumption which I I feel
we benefit from there's a story
vanitas called the artist life that I
like a lot because it has a young
painter who gets fired up in a kind of
class about painting and then discovers
it's actually almost nicer and easier to
just live like an artist but not do any
more pain
and that's kind of the person I've
taught in some other locations but it's
rarely the kind of person we get here
because it really is a place where the
atmosphere is you make things and you
have to do a lot of work you were
talking about how in Opera especially
it's such a collaboration do you feel
like all those collaborators are
contributing to the story you're telling
or are they getting in the way
especially because we're such a visual
Society and the designers and the
directors and the actors themselves who
are singing and yet they're presenting a
visual picture and and they think that
they themselves are contributing to the
story does that destroy what you're
doing does it corrupt what you're doing
or do you feel like they are helping you
to tell the story that you're doing with
the music opera is a very strange world
and a gigantic machine
and I'll just mention two of the people
that I've developed a most respect for
the prompter and and the stage manager
who calls all the signals for all the
people who are trying to make make the
stage change in time for the next scene
to go on and those are things that we
don't see when we're there but if
they're know those people are not
phenomenally good you don't have a you
know you don't have an evening I think
that's one of the fascinating things
about the theater and it's one of the
things that makes it very accident-prone
and dangerous as well
I've had this vision of the artist
perhaps to provide by a sculptor who
stands in front of a piece of marble and
envisions the hole and then slowly
chisels his way into a final form where
he can deal with detail and yet I heard
each of you I think refer to what I
would consider an opposite approach of
starting with fragments and putting
together fragments and finding a context
for fragments so building up from from
fragments and details to a larger vision
rather than starting with a vision and
chiseling your way down to the details
actually I think that there is I mean I
feels very familiar that description of
this the sculptor I think what you what
he's doing first staring at that piece
of stone is waiting for the stone to
speak to him and certain pieces of stone
remain obstinately still they just stay
large chunks of marble and in others in
the grain in something about the
alteration within the color he sees the
beginning of a gesture of the gesture of
a chisel and then once that has been
affected he and the stone are in
dialogue that seems sort of familiar
even though I have nothing to point to
in my medium that says block of marble
but it feels like it feels like there's
a world and you have to give it form the
way you would look at the stone and see
there's something in it resident within
it but I can't say what it is
it
your question made me think of that
great Rodin sculpture of course in which
he seizes the figure out of this
unfinished piece of marble read Rodin
wouldn't finish the sculpture completely
would always leave a piece the way it
was to show you how to create a work of
art it's it's a dance with your material
also a battle with your material but you
are locked together with it mr. Burson
did you write your own libretto yes
which came first and how did how did the
process take place I had a lot of music
before I wrote the libretto and I fitted
the libretto to the music that I had but
that's just my method and obviously I
had to have a complete libretto before I
was going in to end of the piece and the
mistakes I made with the libretto
created the most intractable problems
with the piece
if a colleague of yours in the physical
or social sciences arrived in your
office and said I'm writing a grant to
understand the scientific basis of this
thing that you artists called the muse
what advice would you give that person
each of you has expressed some criticism
of your own works in terms of you know
things that weren't satisfying about
them how do you decide when a work is
done versus it needs revision or you
just want to throw it out and start
something brand new I write novels and
those take a lot of time they take years
to write and I think finally I admit
that I've run out of energy that
whatever energy I had to put into this
work is that an in now it's disappeared
and then then the books at an end I read
that's the dissatisfaction I can't do
anything more I would like to but I
can't well a similar sensation she said
that she got to the end of the of that
novel that she was reading from and it
was not quite what she thought it was
going to be that's not always a bad
feeling you get to the end something is
not what you even we're shooting for but
it's something else and I think you get
to a point where you accept that and in
my case I am always very anxious to go
on whether it's a run out of energy or
just impatience I don't know what it
does seem that there is a point at which
you you do want to go and in the Opera
world that's still a point where people
are telling you you should be making
changes so
we do know that I can add anything to
what has been said and as point a pole
well I've been mainly writing now
constellation so that the books are
really supposed to be taken as entities
yeah very clearly I know when I'm at the
end a voice is spent or an idea is
depleted and then there may be a lot of
work still to do which I embark on but I
know and sometimes I'm wrong actually I
have made mistakes and realized that I
was that something else had to be added
but you realize that in in various ways
you realize that as you attempt to order
the material and that the the form that
you had in mind is not going to work
with this particular set of mosaic
pieces but usually yeah something it's
it's depleted it's finished you've done
what you can do in this with this seems
like a range of notes to me I mean that
may sound awful to you but that's what
it seems like you you you've chosen you
haven't chosen it's been visited on you
a set of Givens and you explore them as
deeply as you can and then the impulse
is exhausted it doesn't feel I don't
yeah that's what it feels like
one of the things that when we talk
about the arts and MIT to our students
is that what they need to understand
often is that you can't always gone
through a B and then you're done it's
not a linear process most of the time
and in fact Louise talked about everyone
could always one of the things that MIT
we talked about with students is that
art is not a linear process you can't
design something that you know is going
to go from A to B and when you get to be
you're done and one of the best things
about the Arts at MIT is in fact
teaching students that not everything is
linear and in fact Louise told us about
one of I guess her most recent
collection Vita Nova that she started
with the last poem and then how do you
know when you're done you need you know
she so all of those things happen right
now whether we are depleted whether we
have exhausted ourselves whether in fact
this was the colloquium it should have
been it is over
[Laughter]
you